hi guys today I'm gonna tell you how to
build your very own wireless monitor so
that you can see what you're shooting
without having to be wired to the camera
and you can show it to your friends and
they don't have to bother you when
you're trying to get your shot so a
professional wireless monitor can be
incredibly expensive that's why I'm
gonna tell you how to build your own
it's still I can be incredibly cheap
it'll probably cost you in the range of
three hundred to five hundred dollars to
build it but it's an incredibly useful
tool to have let's get started to build
a wireless monitor you're going to
proceed a monitor I'd recommend a
lilliput monitor you can get them on
Amazon for pretty cheap I have this rig
on the monitor which lets you hold it in
your hands it's incredibly convenient
it's a CPM monitor rig there will be
links in the description by the way for
all this stuff I'm talking about the
other core component is your transmitter
this is a Nereus Ares pro there's other
types of wireless transmitters basically
if you go to Amazon and you type in
wireless hdmi you'll see a bunch of
different types of things like this it's
also very useful if you want to play
like games on your computer on your TV
and sitting in your living room and
they're not next to each other you can
use a wireless monitor system to
actually have your computer run to your
TV pretty cool we just repurposed it to
use it for a wireless monitor this
system has arranged about 30 feet
through walls to about 60 feet
line-of-sight it's full 1080p 60 frames
a second it pretty much no latency so
you can actually pull focus using the
wireless monitor so it's a very useful
tool that have the one other thing you
need to think about its of course
batteries if you're gonna be a wireless
you need to have a wireless power source
in this case I have a big honking
battery to power the receiver it doesn't
need to be this big and I'll go into
that a little bit and then I also have
another battery to power the monitor
monitor it sucks a lot of juice so let's
get started breaking this down showing
you guys what you need to get and how
you need to arrange your system to build
a functioning wireless monitor you'll
need your lilliput monitor and you're
going to need the rigging to go around
it you'll have to experiment with it you
of course don't need to use the rig I'm
showing you you don't even need a rig at
all but you need the lilliput monitor
and on that monitor you need a way to
attach the battery for the monitor the
battery for the receiver and that's
actually about it in this case what I've
built is I had this little rig here that
this big battery clips into
and then I built a little pouch out of
gaff tape with a little velcro flap that
this battery fits into and then I've
used airsoft connectors which I've wired
in to the battery and to the monitor and
I simply plug them together and that
powers the monitor well for the receiver
right here you can basically use any
kind of iPhone charging battery
basically anything that has a USB out in
terms of power because this receiver is
actually just powered off of USB five
volts
however it has a bit of a funky
connection it has the USB on one end and
the little round cylinder on the other
end and you can get these cables pretty
much anywhere Amazon Google the Internet
for like five to ten bucks
anyways plugs in the receiver and then
you plug the USB end into your phone
charging battery or in this case I this
big laptop battery and that will power
the receiver then you also need a very
short HDMI cable it's very short HDMI
cable will run from the receiver into
the monitor and that's your full monitor
setup that's it super light handheld
easy maneuver the battery powering
monitor here will last for about four
hours the battery powering the receiver
will last about two days I kind of over
killed it on the battery power your
receiver but whatever on the camera side
of things you have your transmitter it's
really tiny it's almost like a USB flash
drive when you get it it comes with a
little nine degree angle that you can
put on the top of it I'd actually
recommend it because it makes it easy
just to velcro this to the side of your
camera and you can have your cable come
off and plug into your HDMI port so
really compact really slim now of course
you need a way to power the transmitter
depending on what type of system you're
using you really need to come up with a
different way to power this in my case
we're using big honkin batteries that
power our red camera they have something
on them called the V tab which is this
little thing right here so we actually
have a D tap two USB connector that we
made right here so we can actually power
our little transmitter off the same
battery that's powering their camera
really convenient don't need extra
batteries in the camera this
one cable and that's it now most of you
guys will probably be shooting on DSLRs
or Sony camcorders or other types of
systems now for that you might just want
to get another iPhone battery similar to
the one that we would have on our
monitor and you just plug your little
USB cable in from the iPhone battery to
the transmitter and like velcro to your
camera small compact lightweight out of
the way all right time to get specific
what do you get what do you buy a
lilliput monitor 1080p with HDMI input
so if you don't want to power it off
these little bricks that you can get you
can build your own the monitor can be
powered off of a DC connection also one
of those little cylinder gold connectors
that slide into those holes you can take
that and the connector that fits it and
splice in a little connector for another
type of battery in this case I use
airsoft connectors if you guys need help
on wiring just do a little Google search
or hop on to a forum people will help
you it's very straightforward
if I looked at the label for this
monitor it says Operation volts 12 volts
so I need make sure whatever battery I'm
running into the monitor is a 12 volt
battery in this case I'm a nickel metal
hydride battery 12 volts with another
airsoft connector spliced onto the end
so I just slip it into my little spot
that I made for it connect the two
connectors and now my monitor is powered
the next step is powering your receiver
you have your USB battery it'll have a
USB plug on the battery and I'll have a
little cylindrical plug input on the
receiver and the receiver I think comes
with a cable in this case I have a
little velcro mount here on this little
thing stick it on the monitor I have the
battery stick that on the monitor plug
it all in and you're good to go there
and that is the entire monitor package
moving to the camera side of things the
transmitter what do you need to power
this just a simple iPhone battery or
Android battery some sort of USB
charging device if you are running a
more beefy system than it runs with
bigger batteries and has DTaP you'll
want a DTaP to 5 volt converter aka USB
now where do you get this these are kind
of hard to find I've seen a couple in
America but they're like a hundred bucks
and that's a lot of money for a cable
here's the easy way to do it you get a
little
adapter that goes in the cigarette
lighter it takes in a full 12 volts
which is what this will put out and it
has a 5 volt output on the other end you
can also get a D tap just basic DTaP
connection online look around for them
you can wire that D tap up to this
little cigarette lighter by popping it
open you'll see where the connectors go
and this turns into just a basic 5 volt
out takes your 12 volts from the battery
turns it into 5 volts with your little
car cigarette lighter adapter or if you
do enough surging and dig deep enough on
eBay you can find a little module that
will do it for you as well which is what
I found here you don't know some need to
bother with all this big battery stuff
you don't need to bother with the DTaP
stuff it's almost simpler if you just
get one of those phone charging
batteries then it's just a basic USB
cable went into the battery other end
into your transmitter done and of course
tiny HDMI cables are run to your butt
camera it probably good to show it's all
looks like when it's up and running I'm
gonna grab the camera
[Applause]
[Music]